Daniel let me know that today I'll be
talking about two intertwined papers um
that yeah I've been working on at the
same time
um so if you've seen me talk about 81
Barbies before there will be new stuff
today also
uh batch arguments they're smart the
Snorks for batch NP that both I'll be
shaken we're talking about in the
morning
okay so this talk our main question that
we're trying to to answer is whether or
not we can generically boost the
succinctness of barks or Smarties for
batch NP
so if we think about K as being the
number of statements in our batch and
here the we're thinking about the proof
length Pi in terms of the witness length
uh W so the most pathetic part we can
imagine is something that all it does is
compress a tiny tiny bit so of course if
you're thinking about the fact that we
want to basically prove K and P
statements the most trivial thing we
could do is just send K Witnesses right
and so then then the length of the proof
will be K times the length of one
witness this is like just doing a tiny
bit better than that basically the worst
possible thing you can do while still
being non-trivial
given a barg that has this spoof length
we can generically boost it to one that
has proof like much more along the lines
of what Abhishek we're talking about in
the morning one where the multiplicative
blow up in the length of one witness is
log K or poly log k
then we can actually boost all the way
to a perfect barg in which the length of
the proof is rate one so just the length
of one witness with an additive
follow-up in the an additive Factor um
in the in the security parameter which
is really the best possible we can hope
for certification for NP um since we
still have like in the the definition in
the morning we want statistical
soundness on one witness we can't really
hope to shrink any more than this we're
always going to need to have like the
proofing at least like the one witness
but we can get it all the way down to
there and it turns out we can go all the
way from the worst possible thing to the
best possible thing generically using
what's called a fully local summer
cystically binding hash family which
I'll Define and construct in this talk
so what does this mean for us especially
like at this Workshop minimal
assumptions and cryptography it means
that when we're trying to think about
building bargs which I think we got a
lot of motivation for why we might care
about that stuff in the morning they're
helpful to build snarks for other
applications as well all we need to do
is try to do better than the trivial
thing which is sending all K Witnesses
if you can do any better than that then
we can get all the way to the best
things that we want generically so we
don't don't need to open the box of what
the the pathetic bar construction looks
like
so it turns out it's known that we can
get from
um the proof length being uh K to the
one minus Epsilon times the minus length
here we can already go all the way to
the proof length being K Over poly
Lambda for some like sufficiently large
polynomial security parameter times this
this is already known
um and so in our work we'll basically
start from here and we'll get to polylog
and and further
um all the way up to to rate one
sometimes
yeah so that's I mean this is uh like
where Senate implies this
course
what's the question I think they start
off
really saying there's even worse
oh oh sorry sorry I understand okay no
yes we need we do need to have uh some
like we need to have some uh gain in
terms of case sorry yes we need some
minor gains in terms of k
um before we can start to like fully
boost the same guess all the way but
thanks
any other questions so
um just to kind of oh yeah here by SSP I
mean some are just statistically finding
um and I'll talk more in more detail
about this um throughout the talk
okay so just so that we're all on the
same page in terms of notation
um I'm talking throughout this talk
about non-interactive batch arguments so
um I'm not going to be doing future
transforms or anything here we're
starting with non-attractive objects and
we're just boosting assisting this and
everything is still going to be
non-interactive
um we're also thinking about bargs for
the index language um as obviously
mentioned this morning this is kind of a
way that we can think about the
verifiers being very efficient it
doesn't necessarily need to read case
statements um if we kind of frame the
language as being one where the
statements are actually just indices and
we think about kind of the the
description of the language L is going
to include basically the actual
statements themselves
um completeness just as we want honestly
generated troops are accepted and
soundness is the same kind of somewhere
statistical soundness notion we've
talked about where we have statistical
soundness for a particular statement I
star and the common reference string
will computationally hide the value of I
star
so the for all of our all of the bars
I'm considering this talk will be uh
these index bars uh
I think you could just repeat what you
just said for soundness oh yes okay so
well yes we have statistical soundness
for statement I star and the CRS
computationally hides the value of ISR
so you should think about this in terms
of basically like you can embed some
value into the CRS um on which you would
be able to catch a cheating approver and
then you can basically move it around
without approver knowing so in a
security proof you would be able to
catch them um wherever a pooper is
trying to cheat and so this kind of
gives us the soundness that we want um
and we'll talk a little bit more about
kind of how this is enough for for
various applications
so first let me also just say why do we
care about going all the way to rate one
a lot of the things we saw in the
morning you can actually get away with
using a barg that has this like poly log
K dependence but there's a lot more that
we can do once we once we boost all the
way to Signature to rate one most
importantly it lets us Embark a barg
without the proof size growing too much
so supposing that we start with you know
a bunch of witnesses
person IP computation we can barg these
Witnesses
um to create some proofs and further by
these while the size as we're going up
the tree is not going to go it is only
going to have an additive blow up as we
increase levels of the tree um whereas
before if we have you know sickness
being poly log K times the length of a
witness um we're gonna have a
multiplicative as we're going up on
levels of this tree
um so a a very cool application of this
is incrementally verifiable computation
and I'll talk about this more at the end
of my talk Depending on time but uh
basically a rate one barg will give us
IVC which you can think about
intuitively as being an updatable snart
um so a snarg that we can continue to
update for like kind of more time steps
without the size of the proof growing
too much
um okay so that's basically a statement
of our main result and why we care about
it
um now let's let's take a Sab at
actually trying to construct these
things I'm going to start with some
super high level intuition of the
template of how this construction will
go and then we'll fill in the details
and see the issues that arise and how we
fix them uh as we continue
any questions
okay so we're starting with these bugs
that have like very very bad to sickness
and we want that we obviously want to
remove the dependence on K which is the
number of instances
so we're going to use this pathetic bar
to shrink the sides of each witness
we're not going to use the bar on all K
of these because then we'll like the
resulting proof would have a size
dependence on K so our hope is to
basically be able to use our pathetic
body to individually shrink each of
these Witnesses
and then uh we hope that we're going to
be able to make them small enough so we
can fold them in a two to one way and
recurse on K over two computational
witnesses which have the same length as
the original ones I know this is like
this is just the kind of what we're
going to try to do I'll explain how we
actually do this in a minute um but the
high level idea is very similar to the
kind of uh recursive constructions that
we saw in the morning as well
I'm going to try to First shrink our
Witnesses and then recurse those are the
two main steps that we need to do
so how do we actually do this
so again we want to shrink the size of
each witness and what we have the
ingredient that we have is this bark
that has pretty bad succinctness so
we're going to use this Berg to create a
snark that has pretty bad succinctness
um but enough that it'll still shrink a
little bit
and then an important thing to note here
is that these snargs are going to be
computed relative to some hash of all of
the witnesses so here we're going to
think about Computing some hash value H
which is a summer system binding hash of
all K Witnesses and we're going to
compute these these snargs Pi with
respect to this hash so what do I mean
by this
boundaries for bits right yes um
bugs for single instance I'm about to
explain how that works yeah so this is
just like the general outline what we
what do we want from these groups I
basically like we're trying to describe
what we want
and I'll explain how we actually how we
actually um instantiate them but what we
want is that um we have this hash value
um and this is going to provide
basically the the summer cities to be
binding on the the instance on a
statement I star and in fact we can
extract one witness
um witness w w sub I start from the hash
value H and what we want is that each of
these proofs Pi I
um should basically be a certificate
that the hash value has a valid witness
underneath it so we're gonna have Pi one
we'll certify that H has a value minus
W1 pi two that has a hashes a valid
witness W2 and so on so forth so do we
understand what we're trying to do I'll
not basically the next thing I'm going
to do is explain how do we actually
construct these Foods Pi because it's
very uh it should not be obvious the
ingredient that we have is empathetic
bark and these pies are really pathetic
snarks so we have to do a transformation
but
um this is what we want out of our
constructions of these beautify these uh
this is like the goal is that they
should be a certificate that each hash
is a valid witness and now we're about
to kind of see how can we actually do
that
and what we can do is it's too fast for
me um so
the hash is a hash function it's
somewhere statistically binding are you
thinking of it as locally openable or
that doesn't matter I'm going to talk
about it a lot later
um it's it's gonna basically the problem
that will arise is based on the size of
opening to this hash function and we're
going to fix the problem
but for now I think just like just think
about it as a regular summer system you
might be hash function
okay so and I'm thinking about this
scenario is proving an end statement for
now uh yes so basically the the snarg is
going to prove the statement that this
is a valid one for this for this
language
so the way that we can try to compute
these proofs Pi
um we're going to they're actually going
to be um snorings in the ram model or
Ram snarks um so again we have this hash
H which is a summer statistically
binding hash on all K of our Witnesses
and now let's think about trying to
compute just one of these Pi eyes so for
some particular I we want to compute a
snarg which says that hashes like among
all of these W1 to WK there is a valid
witness W sub I
so first we think about you know M here
being the basically NP verifier for this
language we can think about running
um the the NP verifier M on the witness
W sub I and having like basically T
states of this computation
um if we hash all of these states again
using a summer specifically binding hash
function
um we're then going to be able to use
our barg um with t instant T statements
to prove uh so let me now explain what
the witnesses for that are the proof Pi
uh Pi prime using our pathetic bar has
Witnesses Omega 1 through Omega T where
each witness has basically two parts it
consists of two states of this empty
verifier machine with openings to the to
the hash value the the hash of all of
these States it also um like at various
points in this computation they'll be
reading from memory and we need to
include openings of the bits that I read
from memory to ensure that those ones
are actually correct so we should think
about basically like each witness
corresponds like one time step
um of this NP verification on the
witness W sub I we need to check to make
sure that the state transitions
correctly we all need to make sure that
if we read a bit for memory so this
would be by memory here I mean w1cwk so
assuming that we've read some bit from
the witness wi I mean to make sure that
that one was actually correct so the
witnesses for this so here we're using
pi I is going to be computed using our
pathetic Barb and it has t statements
total
um and the teeth the eye thitness again
consists of basically State I minus 1
State I with openings of the hash value
and then in addition openings to
whatever bits are read from memory so
this in total of the hash value V and
the proof Pi I is going to be our snarg
pie which certifies that each hashes a
valid witness W sub I yeah so just to
make sure this is V sub I and Pi primes
yes sorry yeah they should be basically
five months away yeah tell us how to put
them together no
it's possible that some for some I in
fact you read all the bits of wi right
yes so we we are so so so
oh no I mean think about it as basically
we're reading like one like a turing
machine that reads one bit at a time it
has like a head somewhere and really but
it's possible when you have many uh when
you have a barg it's each one of them
you only
you necessarily only read very few bits
so this so This bi and Pi Prime I are
being computed only for one of the
statements for trying to borrow uh we're
hashing all of K Witnesses together but
this everything here
um like yeah sorry this should be a bit
one with it's possible that for some
witness you read all the bits of that
witness now over time yes but like we
we're thinking about our barg as being
over all the time steps so as long as
you don't read you all of the fits of
the witness on a single time step then
that you run into that problem
so plugging now this into the beginning
of our construction
um we're going to have each of these Pi
sub I's will be the prophetic cram snark
that I described for the the relevant
witness
um and if we get the sickness that we
need we can do basically then our
folding trick to combine each two two
groups Pi I into one computational
witness and now we would only have K
over two statements to prove and we can
recurse because we have not blown up the
size of our Witnesses we've only reduced
the number of statements we're trying to
prove without increasing the size of the
statements which means that we can just
continue on with the exact same thing we
again apply pathetic snarks to each of
these uh the verifications of each of
these Witnesses
um hash them the songs are computed with
respect to the hash and we just keep
doing this until we have only one um
proof pilot basically continuing all the
recursion all the way down the tree
this is what our final proof would look
like it would consist of K log K hash
values for each level of the tree and
one final proof pi
so the polybaric verifier what does it
need to do it needs to check consistency
between these hash values I did not
describe how this is done but basically
you can look to make sure that the hash
H1 is hashing something that you know
does include openings to the hash value
agents a lot you can check consistency
and then you only need to verify this
Final computational witness um the
pathetic gram snark which is the
basically you think of like the root of
the the recursion tree
so this seems like you know we've done
what we wanted yeah
so so we can merge them if they're if
the length of one witness is like less
than half of the size of the original
witness right so if we get that
distinctness then we can just you know
just literally concatenate them and
merge fine whatever right but of course
I mean as anyone who's like worked on
this stuff a lot maybe you could predict
I've actually been cheating and we're
not like what what with the the tools
that I've described using just like a
regular summer system binding hash
function and defining the random this
way we're not actually shrinking at all
and let me explain why
so recall that this proof Pi I the for
the pathetic ramstars part of the
witnesses um for the barg that we're
using under the hood is openings to this
hash value right whenever we're reading
bits we're thinking about the fact that
this this Pi eye is a snark for the NP
verification computation and so it needs
to read some stuff from the witness
right
um and all of those things that are read
from the witness to ensure that they're
correct we need to include openings to
the hash value h and as it turns out
these openings are going to be large uh
which means that we're not actually
going to to have any shrinking we're
calling that the hash value H is
somewhere statistically binding on an
entire witness
um it turns out that existing SSP
constructions will have any opening even
an opening of one bit
um if the opening is with respect to the
hash value H the opening will grow with
a size H
so let me explain why this is
so starting with existing SSP hash
family constructions um this is like
which I could work since 2015. I'm going
to talk about the simpler case where we
only care about being binding on like
one block of the the input rather than
being binding on arbitrary uh indices
um but our constructions extend to that
case and I can talk about that more um
Depending on time so let's think first
what if we were just to use the
construction in HW how would we have how
would we build an SSP hash which is um
binding on like one block of size M so
you think about here dividing the string
X into K blocks and each block will have
size M we're going to be binding on one
block okay so the construction in HW
gives us a way to uh be binding on one
bit of a stream so we can start by
trying to we'll we'll do one we'll
compute one hash value H1 which is
somewhere statistically binding on the
first bit of this block that we want you
should think about if you're not
familiar with this construction think
about it as basically being a tree of
OTS where you know based on you know
which index you want to be Summer's
discrete binding on and so which um at
each level of the tree you need to just
use the you need to have a different uh
basically index that you're going to
wait sorry a different like receiver bit
um based on which
index I want to be as a speed on
um and you can then compute essentially
what would be H1 would be functionally
just an encryption of the bit xq1 um and
in that sense it's binding on that fit
um so this is just the existing
construction for HW applied to you know
a string of like K times M to be
somewhere specifically binding on one
bit this is like would be the first
component of our hash value we of course
want to be binding on M bits so we would
just repeat this process M times we hash
the string x m times each time being
some resist to be binding on one bit of
the block that we want
so our final hash value H would just be
all M of these hash values uh which is
now some are specifically binding on the
entire block
the problem that occurs here is that now
say we want to locally open one bit of
the string x with respect to the hash
value h
we can locally open to one of these hash
values H sub I so we can locally open to
the the hash value H sub 1 for example
um and this is just basically a path to
this tree so this local opening will be
small and that's fine the problem is
that in order to locally open one bit of
X we actually need to include M of these
paths because we need to locally open
for each of the different M hash values
because recall each of these hash values
is computed by hashing the entire string
and when you're locally opening you
shouldn't know necessarily really you
shouldn't you should not need to like be
deciding how to open based on where your
your summer specifically binding so you
need to compute openings with regards to
all M of these hash values and oh sorry
and so that means that now a local
opening for one bit has size that
depends on M so again here like thinking
about the the string is long the size of
the string has length K times M this
hash value has size that depends on M of
course because we want to be able to
extract it um bits from it or it's
summer since we binding on M bits
um and we would hope that a local
opening for one bit can also be short
but using just the regular HW
construction
um we will not have that happen we'll
have that instead the size of a local
opening will depend on end
up with a similar construction and there
it was resolved by hashing separately
the first bit of explanix students
why does this mean that our construction
doesn't work these these pie eyes are
actually are actually large right
they're actually going to be even in
fact a size bigger than the original
witness because a miniature include
these openings to the hash value so we
cannot actually shrink at all and when
we do when we just apply our pathetic
ramp snark um using a regular SSB hash
function we're not going to shrink and
thus we can't get anywhere so really the
Crux of the matter here is trying to
make the openings of this opening the
local openings for this hash function
small and not have dependence on how
many bits the hash value is uh summer
statistically binding on
so now let me Define
um the object that we construct to solve
this problem which is a fully local
summer system binding hash function
so we think the setup is very similar to
an SSB hash function where we have a
hash key and a string X along with some
indices we want to be uh statistically
binding on
we should be able to Hash this string X
and extract whatever bits we want using
a trapdoor
we should also be able to locally open
any particular bit of this string X to a
local opening row this row should be
short it should have size polylamba
furthermore we should be able to verify
this opening without actually reading
the whole hash value H we should be able
to verify this opening reading just an
honestly compute a digest so think of
this here digest as just being a Merkle
tree with a collision assistant hash
function we should be able to verify the
opening row reading only the root
of the hash value H which means that our
entire verification procedure will
happen in poly Lambda time and of course
basically like even if the opening row
was itself short but the verification
algorithm still needed to read H it
wouldn't run in time polylender it would
need to run in time that depends on M so
we avoid that problem by having openings
verifiable against just a hash root of
the hash value page
any questions about the definition
so now let me describe the construction
so as Omar mentioned basically the idea
is going to be
actually
so
two things are local
the first is the length of an opening
Row the length of an opening row which
is an opening for one bit of x should
not depend on the number of bits that we
want to be statistically binding on it
should just uh it should be to say poly
Lambda and log in everything else
the second thing that's local about it
is that we do not need to read the whole
hash value H in order to verify this
opening round because of course the hash
value age has to have like that depends
on the number of businesses we found on
because otherwise we can't specifically
mine on them and so how can we avoid the
problem of needing to have verification
have time depends on this we can have
the verification algorithm only look at
a honest computer digest of hash
which means that all the entire
Recreation process happens in time that
does not depend on how many bits each is
the display
Supply
yes well the only thing only age is
going inside I these two do not
if you just use like statistically uh
right so we use just the regular
um like the construction rate shw
um basically you have to include that
it's true that
um with this construction if we're
supposed to just be binding on one bit
we'll have a local opening which is
basically just a path through this tree
um to compute the hash value but suppose
that we want to open of course like we
need to hide the the bits that we're
acceptable on right which means that
suppose you want to open some bit of
this this string X we need to open with
respect to all of these like sub hash
values that we've computed
um Each of which is binding on some
index that we don't know like maybe the
the you know maybe when we're picking
some random index in the string X and we
want to open you know x sub J it's
possible that H sub 1 is by an x sub J
or h of two is mining on an x sub J or H
sub m is mining in x sub J which means
that in order to get the you know
statistical uh properties that we want
we need to open we need to provide an
opening with respect to all M of these
hash values you see does this come up
like in a security proof so
where's this what is it wrong
I don't understand um so the reason why
this is relevant is because of this
basically that we're hoping that we're
going to be able to shrink our Witnesses
using these Ram smarts but because their
openings are large we're not actually
shrinking okay but with uh with the new
uh with our fully local SSP hash we will
be able to share okay yes because we'll
have the property that our openings are
small and the notification time is short
so we will actually be able to shrink
our Witnesses uh and uh basically like
continue on our recursion
so the construction
um as Omar mentioned basically is to try
to just instead of just hatching the
whole string every time and then uh
needing to open to all M hash values
we're going to reorganize our string so
first we're going to Hash the first bit
of every block
should I put our first component H1 then
hash the second bit of every block and
so on so forth
um so we still have M hash values
um but now the difference The crucial
difference to think about here is that
when we're opening one bit of X we only
need to open with respect to one of
these hash values not all M of them
so what is a local open up so the hash
value H is just you know all M of these
these hash values each one through hm
um when we're looking at trying to
compute a local opening we think about
taking the so here digest is just again
a Merkle tree with a collision resistant
hash function
um when you want a local opening what is
the local opening consist of it consists
of the local opening
um of whatever bit we want with respect
to the relevant hash value
it you have to include also that hash
value itself in the local opening
because the local opening remember is
only getting verified against just the
route the the verifier for the local
opening does not have access to this
whole hash value H so you provide them
with just the relevant one and then you
also provide the path through the tree
to show that the hash value you gave is
actually what was uh that digested that
to this route
so because again here the difference
between this and the the construction I
showed before is that there we were
hatching the whole string M times and so
when we wanted to open something in the
string we needed to open it with regards
to all M of those hash values versus
here we're like segmenting we're readers
by kind of reorganizing the string and
each bit of the string is only getting
hashed once which means that when we
open it we don't need to open it at
times we can just open it once
so
you are assignment
so well and SSB itself would already
assume uh an OT or like LHC or something
so
so the the compiler that you're showing
is actually has like you need to assume
SSD right it's like SSB plus uh plus bar
and just if I just gave you SSD just by
itself you just use it to also
constructive bar or like what is known
um I mean yeah
so we we can so we have SSB from any big
one OT so we can do
um we're from uh lwe or deal so for I
guess in existing constructions of bargs
all existing contractions of barbs rely
on assumptions from which we also have
SSD so yeah sure but generically
generically I don't think
yeah I don't think it's known for that
yeah
it's true you're saying it the other way
around yes I think that message me from
from bars so we would not need to if we
have the borrowing that we want to boost
we should be able to boost it without
needing to have it oh so you don't
actually need the addition oh yeah sorry
you need the bar to be somewhere if we
have a bar with the security properties
that I described we will also have
everything that we need to boost it all
the way to grade one
so what have I done so far
um I've basically shown how to boost a
pathetic bar into a fully log bark by
constructing and then using this fully
local SSP hash family
um I just want to take a moment to talk
about the more General construction so
but more General I mean here we're being
always SSP on just one block or we had
this really nice structure to the string
and the the indices that we're being
binding on
um because we think that this this
object probably has applications
elsewhere
um it has applications to things like
verifiable PIR and whatnot we did also
do a construction for the more General
case
um where we want to be binding on any
set of mndc it's not necessarily like x
uh you know I through I plus m
so of course in this case the CRS needs
to be long because information
theoretically needs to encode the
indices that you're going to be finding
on but we kind of have similarly to the
hash value we have that the openings can
be verified against just the digest of
the CRS so verification time is still
fast
um a little bit of intuition for the
construction you basically just use a
prf or a Lambda wise independent hash
function
um to partition the blocks
so that you don't have too many indices
to be SSB done in any block but I'm just
think this is mostly just a side comment
um for this for the boosting
applications we only need the the
version where we're like SSP on one one
block of the string okay so coming back
to this now the construction that I told
you actually works so plugging in our
fully local access some are specifically
binding hash function and using um
basically then our pathetic Ram snar
Construction this construction will work
and we'll have boosted all the way
successfully to poly log barks which
means that again the length of the proof
is going to have multiplicative blow up
um that's law and poly log k
okay so again just taking a step back to
like what I said I was going to do over
the whole talk we've now done the first
step of boosting which is that we've
gone from this pathetic bard
to a poly log bar using a fully local
summer cystic binding hash function can
you remind us where the log came from ah
yes the log came from there's log K hash
values here it's basically the levels of
the tree
we still need to do our second boosting
step which is going from poly log bargs
to these Rate One bars
question
the idea is very similar but because
we're starting with a much better bark
we actually don't even need to recurse
so again the first level idea is that we
want to shrink heat the size of each
witness using our poly log bar and what
we're going to do is the exact same uh
so the construction that I showed before
of using a pathetic bar to build a
pathetic ramp snark identically gives us
a polylogram snark from a poly log bar
so we can basically do the exact same
thing that we did before except using
our poly log barg as the ingredient
instead of using our pathetic part
you're then going to take a fully local
San Francisco binding hash of all K
Witnesses
um so we're Computing this is what gives
us our extractability property and again
each Pi I here is certifying that hashes
a valid uh witness WI
so this part is like exactly the same as
the the first Construction
then instead of recursing we can
actually just barg our Witnesses again
because now that we have a poly log bark
um the size of the spinal proof pie will
not have a dependence on K uh because
the the length of this proof Pi will be
a polylog k times the length of one of
these proofs Pi I which is already short
by the physics of our polyblock bar so
it's essentially just doing uh it's just
a faster version of what we did last
time because we have a much stronger
bard
the final proof will then consist of
just the hash value H which again is a
flssp of the witnesses W1 through WK
and the proof Pi which is a poly log bar
of poly log Ram snacks
all that the rate one bar verifier has
to do is verify uh This polylog Bar Pi
with respect to the hash value H and to
extract a witness it can extract from
the hash value age
so you get stuck at the W because you
need to program it into the SSD valve
right so for applications so it's it's
actually generically true that
um a bar with the soundness that we've
described like this statistical sign of
someone index you can generically be
start using a an SSB um hash function to
one where you can actually extract the
witness wi
um and so like really there's not we
don't have any hope for like having
proofs length that's going to be shorter
than that well how does it benefit into
construction like oh yeah so here the
fruit pie will be small because it's
kind of a it's like a bark of Snorks
which are already small and the hash
value can have size W
um and in fact it will it needs to have
size W of course information
theoretically so now really the question
is
um how can we make our fully local
summer specifically bindings hash family
Rave one because uh remember H is the
flssp of uh K Witnesses
um so if this is Rate One by which I
mean that the length of the hash value
will just be the length of one witness
plus poly Lambda then we're done
so again revisiting um the definition of
our original fully local summer
specifically binding hash family
um our first idea is what if we use a
rate one SSB uh which we have from from
rate10t
um the problem is that okay so suppose
that we just use rate one SSB here what
is the length of this hash value h
quality from okay
oh yeah so basically the the the
Transformations
um like we talked about this is uh
something that's implied by the
existence of a pathetic work and we used
for all of our all of our mistakes
so if we try to just plug in here a ring
one SSB we don't actually get that the
the whole flssp is is rate one and
what's the problem the problem is that
okay so each of these hash values hi is
SSB on one one bit right so if it's rate
one then the length of each of these hi
is like one plus poly Lambda so the
length of this whole thing is still M
times polylamba right using rate one bit
by bit does not help us because uh we
still are going to have the total length
of the hash value is going to be M times
poly Lambda so the second key idea is
that instead of doing things bit by bit
we'll do things chunk by chunk
um where we have chunks of like
sufficiently large polynomial and
security parameter
so now basically instead of having M
hash values total that consists that
make up our hash value H will have M
over B and if we set B large enough
uh then we can have that we can have the
length of this hash value each would be
M times Little M time M times 1 plus a
little of one
um so we can achieve the rate one that
we want by Just Adjust these two things
using a rate one SSB and instead of
doing things bit by bit doing things
um the local opening and everything else
is still like exactly the same in that
to locally open a bit you locally open
the to the SSB hash value you provide
that value and then the path
um
so rate one is is one plus zero one
times W or yes so yes so okay uh this is
let me say so I guess we have
um kind of a couple of results on this
so from the these constructions will
give us this kind of weak rate one in
which we think of it like the length of
the hash value H and then identification
like the proof would be M times one plus
little of one we've also shown um in
this work
um we can get strong rate one in which
the hash value would have just like M
plus polyline like truly rate one only
from LW we don't have that from the
other assumptions because we actually
like open the open the hood of like the
access feed based on lwe and we do a lot
of we do some like crazy stuff there
um we don't have any applications that
we cannot use the rate one for
um all of the applications that we've
seen aggregate signatures incremental
verified computation verifiable PIR et
cetera all their week rate run is
sufficient
um because the level of one is one over
pulling numbers yeah
many times
so
boosted hour or now that we've have this
rank one fully local summer cystically
mining hash family we've where this
construction is also good in that we've
now succeeded in constructing a rate one
bark um using our poly log bark um and
the rate one fully local sometimes
families
questions about this Construction
so again in summary we started with the
these terrible bugs
um that have just a little bit all that
you're doing is a little bit of
shrinking in terms of k
um we're able to assuming rate when OT
boost all of the way
to the best possible bargs where the
length of the proof is basically just
the length of one witness
um these are the full versions of the
two papers that I talked about today for
reference
um in my last couple of minutes I want
to talk about incrementally verifiable
computation
so incrementally reactable computation
is one of the coolest applications of of
rate one barks
um again intuitively it basically is a
snug that's updatable so what does this
mean suppose that I want to compute a
snarg for some computation that takes
time T and T is really big so I don't
actually want to sit around and take all
of the time to compute this through Pi
of course it has to take at least time T
to compute so what am I going to do I'm
going to do a little bit of it I'll do
for a couple of time steps up to time T
sub 1 I'll come I'll compute the proof
Pi sub D1 and I'll save the
configuration of the machine at this
state then I can hand this off to Yao
and y'all can finish she can keep
updating the proof update the
configuration of the machine up until
time T sub 2 she can hand off to the
node we can keep going and all that we
need to hand between each other is this
the sync proof pi and the configuration
of the machine at the time so here The
crucial thing is that we don't need to
sit down and do the whole computation of
the snark at once because we can update
it and the snark stays succinct the
whole time we could even like distribute
the the work of computing the snark um
and in all the ways we have we can also
continue on from this proof Pi
um continue on to to show other things
past the configuration t as well
previously um the only standard model
constructions of this had proof size
polyte and Epsilon this is under by
linear maps and I work by kalai panathin
Yang proof size poly log t for IVC was
only known under non-standard knowledge
assumptions or in the random Oracle
model prior to the the standard
assumption constructions break one parts
the construction is is pretty simple
um that main idea is basically that
um like let me talk you through kind of
the first how would we update for for
the first couple time steps so from time
step one through 2K the proof just
consists of just the list of
configurations all you do is just like
just basically save each configuration
in a list and up until time uh 2K that's
what the proof consists of
After Time step 2K we need to start
making things smaller so we compute a
bark so obviously hash all 2K
configurations and then we compute a
barg which certifies that this actually
hashes consecutive configurations
division
oh so so the the size of our proof will
grow with the size of the the stake here
because this age needs to be some are
justifically binding on the states yes
yeah and in fact because I mean at the
beginning we're just saving like 2K
States um for the beginning the the
first couple um steps
uh once we've computed once we've hashed
these 2K configurations and computed our
bargs we can forget the first K minus
one configurations
um note here I'm not forgetting all of
them the reason for this is just kind of
a a slightly subtle idea that again uh
this is something Abhishek mentioned but
borrowing's compute technically a bunch
of separate statements right and here we
want to prove this like continuous thing
we want to prove that you know the
overlapping uh configurations are the
same which is why we even after hashing
the configuration 0 through 2K and
Computing H1 Pi one we're still going to
keep the configurations K through 2K
until we've accumulated more and we can
hash basically in an overlapping way
um that's the only basically to get IVC
you just need to use Rate One bars
um and the only thing that kind of
causes any sort of issues is the the
idea that you want to make sure that
you're not just proving that you know
configuration zero goes to configuration
K and that conversion K plus one goes to
2K you want to make sure that you cover
basically you want to overlap so that
you don't have any issues with the
boundaries between your batches
after we've accumulated a 3K
configuration uh like up to 10.3k again
we hash and keep forgetting so basically
we go on like this until time step 2K
squared plus K plus minus one or
whatever basically until we've
accumulated a bunch of hashes at the
first level of this tree we just keep
you know saving configurations hashing
forgetting so on so forth
once we have a bunch of hashes at this
level of the tree we do the exact same
thing where we're going to Hash all of
these and then start forgetting the
first half of them and just continue on
um in total we think about having Lambda
levels of our tree um so we can handle
anything at the time T equals to the
Lambda
and uh we're going to basically have
each level of the the the proof um is
never going to contain too many things
because as soon as it grows too large we
can batch and then forget and just keep
going on factions again
how do you choose Kate yes so uh
basically it'll just be a trade-off in
terms of the the sizes of the the things
here until you can choose it how you
want we would choose for example you
could choose Oh you mean you should
choose
k equals 2 is just a little bit
confusing because of this overlapping
that I mentioned so you just want I
think at least k equals three just to
ensure that you can properly overlap
your batches but
um
yes yeah
okay in general case constant yeah
yes um so yeah I'll I'll wrap up there
because I don't think I have time I
guess okay just I can very briefly say
um another immediate application is
aggregate signatures
oh so we we achieve obviously with proof
time um poly log T from standard
assumptions um because of the fact that
we have you know we have bargs from
standard assumptions and now that we can
do sparks all the way to rate one
um rate one barks gives us IVC
um so we we now have IVC under lwe or
Doolin or udh
with your size
oh yes aggregate signatures are
basically another immediate example
because
um the a barg is essentially a signature
aggregator in that it allows you to
basically take a sequence of signatures
and compress them into something where
the length does not depend on how many
signatures that you were trying to
so this is another really cool
application so what do you get for
aggregate signatures no
sorry uh I mean what's the implications
for an aggregate signature from what
assumptions
interesting
so it's the same um we get it from uh
lwe or Zealand orphanage
okay
[Music]
so just just I mean I don't know if
anyone cares but like what about
factoring based assumptions like I don't
know PCR production velocity or
something I wonder what parts we have
from those
just one of those assumptions
anyway
this is probably a silly question but
what happens if you plug in a like like
Mount Read like non-read one like barred
into those applications oh great
question um I mean basically the problem
is that
the the the proof sizes are going to
grow too large so for example here we
have this proof Pi one is going to
basically have the size of just like two
configurations
um and this proof Pi i1 will also
basically have the size into
configurations
um but if we didn't have a rig one bark
then we would have multiplicative blow
up with each level of the tree which
means that by the time that we got up to
you know like several like we need to
support at least Lambda levels of the
tree so by the time you got up to the
top the boots would be too big
okay thanks